- The Facebook Oversight
Board has reaffirmed
its decision to ban former
president Trump from Facebook
causing lots of people
to have really, really
terrible legal takes
including some saying
that the Supreme Court
should overrule Facebook's decision.
Now a couple of things.
Number one, that's not a thing.
You can't appeal a decision
of a non-governmental body
that's not a court to the Supreme Court,
that's just not a thing.
And then number two,
a lot of people talk about Section 230
saying this is big tech
and Section 230 allows them
to do that, that's not true.
The thing that allows
Facebook to discriminate
who is on its platform and
what speeches on that platform
is the first amendment.
You can control who talks in your house
and what speech you wanna
hear in your own house.
It's not Section 230,
it's the first amendment.
So we won't be seeing these guys in court.